So what can that hacker still do?
So this brute force guessing,
they'll have to get hold of
the shadow password files.
They'll learn the hash values.
So let's say there is
a compromise of the system and
that file is exfiltrated or
something like that.
In fact in the past year or
two, there have been several examples
where LinkedIn and Adobe and
others had these password,
derived values from password files,
those were stolen by hackers and
actually made widely available.
So if you have these hash values,
let's say if you get a hold of them,
you're doing brute force
guessing of passwords.
How hard is this task?
One thing we can do is we have
some hardware software and
whatever hash function here,
we're talking MD5.
That's one of the hash
functions that is used.
Publicly available
software that we have, and
certain kind of hardware that is
common and quite popular for graphics.
GPUs are graphics processing unit, and
they're particularly well suited for
doing password kind of calculations or
brute force kind of attacks
we're talking about.
So a GPU with available software
can do 10 to the power 8.
So that's 100 million hashes it
can compute and check per second.
Okay, so if the password is only,
let's say six random upper or
lowercase, okay, 26 lowercase,
26 uppercase, all digits,
that will give us 62 total
number of characters.
If you have 62 possibilities,
and it's 6 characters long,
the first character, there's 62 choices.
The second character,
there's 62 choices, the 6th character,
there's 62 choices.
So total number of possible passwords
we can have is 62 times 62,
6 times, or 62 to the power of 6.
If you actually do your calculation,
you see how much that is.
Divide that number by 10 to the power 8,
because that's how many
we can do per second.
If you try to find that out,
you'll see that this calculation, or
this brute force attack,
guessing attack we're talking about,
can be carried out in about 10 minutes.
One thing we do is we increase
the size of the password.
We ask people to pick longer passwords.
So from six if we go to eight,
of course, the effort for
that hacker is going to go up.
It's going to go up
from minutes to days.
But if you take eight random characters
of the same kind, you would actually
get 62 to the power of 8,
because there are 62 choices for each.
If you add special characters, the
calculation would change a little bit,
but if you calculate this number, again
divide this by 10 to the power of 8,
it's going to give you 6 days.
You don't have to limit yourself
if you're the attacker to one GPU.
If you add GPU, this kind of
computation can be done in parallel and
you can reduce the time
if it's too long.
But the idea here is that brute force
guessing of passwords, even when
they're reasonable respectable length,
is certainly doable for an attacker.